dr nash and total transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives all across the valley
and for dominic it is more than weight
loss take a look
working with dr nash i lost 70 pounds in
three and a half months and reversed my
type 2 diabetes and i feel great dr nash
dominic's transformation is unbelievable
it's amazing what you've done with
dominic tell us more about the guy yeah
so dominic was somebody that found out
that he was pre-diabetic when he was 20
years old he worked for five years
trying to figure out through his own
methods
what to do about it how to lose some
weight and turn it around and ended up
becoming full-blown diabetic by the age
of 25 and that's when he decided to get
serious and do something that's when he
found me he lost a hundred pounds by the
using my program and reversed the
diabetes in three months how come how
come some doctors they can they can
manage these symptoms
but you're making these drastic changes
for people how are you doing this so
unfortunately doctors hands are really
tied when it comes to diabetes because
they can really only use medication and
as the disease progresses and worsens
they'll add insulin uh to the equation
and while those measures will work on
controlling things like blood sugar the
disease and the disastrous symptoms will
continue to worsen and the problem is i
don't think people understand just how
bad the symptoms get we're talking
blindness amputation heart disease
kidney and liver damage and now severe
to fatal outcomes with covid19 on top of
this stubborn weight problem this
obesity that just won't go away
your cat has arrived to join our
interview today i love it when your cat
shows up that's just great i know so he
photobombed my shot with you jason it's
fantastic let's talk about
let's talk about the five metabolic
factors that that you have
right so one of the things that i found
out after my 25-year struggle with
obesity is that for me personally it was
the damage that was driving the weight
problem not the calories and exercise so
those five things are the total in the
total transformation so one is going to
be toxicity the other one is going to be
over fed but undernourished not getting
the proper nutrition to turn the
metabolism around the next one is going
to be the retraining of the hypothalamus
or the set point that tells your body to
stay at a certain weight the a is for
acidity also known as inflammation which
drives stubborn weight to the belly and
then l is the lower the imbalanced
hormones up to seven different hormones
that if they are not in the proper
position in that body you literally
can't burn body fat and every week you
come on the show you've got a special
for us what do you have for us today oh
you know i do so
normally when people come and talk to me
when they go online and do the
evaluation it's 97 to do that but when
las vegas now allows me to talk with jc
about this topic that i'm so passionate
about i have 10 spots available where we
will do that online evaluation for 9.97
you want to go to the website to secure
that spot if you call my office they
don't know about the special they're
going to try to charge you 97
so go to that doctornash.com forward
slash eval those spots go quickly and
make sure that i get a chance to talk to
you and get you the help that you need
to get well